US Vice President Mike Pence has been
criticized for not wearing a mask during
a visit to a Medical Center Penn's
visited the Mayo Clinic in Minnesota on
Tuesday the Research Center later said
on Twitter that he had been informed of
the mandatory mask policy though that
tweet has since been deleted Mike Pence
visited Mayo Clinic in Rochester and
there he did not wear a surgical mask a
mask to cover his face many observers
commented on this the video footage from
the pool accompanying the Vice President
show that he was the only person without
a face mask at that particular clinic
and now the vice president spokesperson
subsequently said that the vice
president gets tested for the virus once
a week and therefore there is no need
for him to wear a mask as he is not
could not be asymptomatic well
health experts point out that that is
not the case he could contract the virus
at any particular stage
a spokesperson for mr. pence also said
that he wanted to look the health
workers directly in the eye to thank
them for this service but the fact
remains that the president he has
refused to wear a face mask the vice
president is not wearing a face mask now
this despite the guidance from the White
House that all in public should be
wearing face masks so the president and
vice president not following the orders
that they themselves are setup